today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
so last night was the second and final
presidential debate and i have to tell
you
for me being so desensitized to this
stuff being so used to what we see and
hear from politicians
uh it is actually an outlier it it
really is a debate that was superlative
compared to other debates in a number of
different ways
number one joe biden did really well i
didn't expect joe biden to come out in
the way we did i knew he would say
things that would make sense but i
didn't imagine that he was going to be
from a tone and optics perspective um
so strong in comparison to donald trump
i
also didn't imagine that donald trump
was going to come out
um almost despondent and barely able to
even respond to joe biden's attacks for
the first 70 percent of the debate
the last 30 percent going to conspiracy
theories and
things that don't make any sense and it
was one of the most uneven debates i can
imagine watching
i thought back to 2012 the famous
um obama romney debate where romney
made kind of a fool out of himself
starting to say things that didn't make
sense and then trying to get obama to
concede something and obama just sitting
there casually saying
please proceed governor and it was very
uneven
but romney's performance was better than
trump's
last night and joe biden just landing
brutal hit after hit on trump trump
seemed almost
slowed down depressed confused
looked like he was taking physical
punches rather than simply metaphorical
ones
in the first debate biden wasn't nearly
as strong
as i'd like to see and trump was kind of
annoying with his childish interruptions
but it was not
so lopsided last night's debate
stunningly one-sided so let's look at
some clips
one quick note excellent job by
moderator kristen welker
she had total control of the debate the
entire time there was no point at which
she was in the chris wallace position of
almost having to beg trump
to stop interrupting uh she in full
control of the entire debate
very very good to see and even from the
get-go i mean trump entering with no
mask
joe biden with a mask all emblematic
a microcosm of the entire portion of the
debate about coronavirus
which was as usual and as expected one
of the worst parts of the debate for
donald trump
trump immediately trying to defend his
work on coronavirus defending the
indefensible
and predictably making no sense talking
about what he's been able to do with
goggles
and how other world leaders have praised
him we have
a problem that's a worldwide problem
this is a worldwide problem
but i've been congratulated by the heads
of many countries
on what we've been able to do with the
if you if you take a look at what we've
done in terms of
goggles and masks and gowns and
everything else and in particular
ventilators we're now making ventilators
all over the world thousands and
thousands a month distributing them all
over the world
joe biden shot out of a cannon
immediately says
listen any president who oversees 220
000 deaths
they can't continue to be president you
don't re-elect
someone on the heels of such a failure
two hundred and twenty thousand
americans dead
if you hear nothing else i say tonight
hear this
anyone is responsible for not taking
control
in fact not saying i'm i take no
responsibility initially
anyone who's responsible for that many
deaths should not remain as president of
the united states of america
we're in a situation where there are a
thousand deaths
a day now a thousand deaths a day and
there are over
70 000 new cases per day
compared to what's going on in europe
as the new england medical journal said
they're starting from a very
low rate we're starting from a very high
rate
the expectation is we'll have another
200
000 americans dead be timed between now
and the end of the year
if we just wore these masks the
president's own advisors have told them
we could save a hundred thousand lives
and we're in a circumstance where the
president thus far and still has
no plan no comprehensive plan
so really not a good start for donald
trump and it got even worse donald trump
tried pulling this thing about
i shut down travel from china and biden
said i was xenophobic
and biden with this was when i thought
joe is really ready
biden with a perfect line which is you
are xenophobic
but not because you shut down travel
from china my response is he is
xenophobic but not because he shut down
access from china and he did it late
after 40 countries had already done that
in addition to that what he did he made
sure that we had 44 people that were in
there
in china trying to get to wuhan to
determine what exactly the source
was what did the president say in
january he said no he said this is
he's being transparent the president of
china is being transparent we owe him a
debt of gratitude we ought to we have to
thank him
this is when in watching trump just
stand there
shaking his head i realized this was not
during the muted microphone phase of the
debate
i realized trump didn't have it trump
was not up to the task
last night and indeed this is where it
really started going off the rails
uh trump been trying to defend his
record bizarrely goes into talking about
joe biden's basement
and joe biden making money that i guess
trump thinks is not
appropriate money for joe biden to have
made your reaction over soon i say we're
learning to live with it we have no
choice we can't lock ourselves up in a
basement like
joe does he has the he has the ability
to lock himself up i don't know he's
obviously made a lot of money someplace
but he has this thing about living in a
basement people can't do that
by the way i as the president couldn't
do that i'd love to put myself in the
basement
so that's an example of trump throwing a
punch that just missed everything like
it just hit nothing
and joe biden in a bunch of these
moments joe biden just smiled and
laughed
and i think that's the right way to
brush off
trump's silly conspiratorial ad hominems
because
if you try to deal with it directly i
don't know how you do it without
sounding defensive
pete but edge edge on fox news has had
some good examples of when he's put on
the defensive
and he hits back and it doesn't seem
like he's on the defensive
he's back to offense i just don't know
that biden would have been able to do it
in this format without
actually seeming defensive which you
don't necessarily want to do so i think
biden just laughing this stuff off was
was perfect it's the right way to do it
joe biden then going after rudy giuliani
not mentioning the borat fiasco but
mentioning many other things that
triggered donald trump well
his buddy rudy giuliani he's being used
as a russian
pawn he's being fed information that is
russian
that is not true and then what happens
nothing happens
and then you find out that everything is
going on here
about russia is wanting to make sure
that i do not
get elected the next president united
states because they know
i know them and they know me
so trump also unable to take that on and
then again donald trump saying when the
topic of his taxes came up
that now his line is he pre-paid
millions of dollars
at the town hall when trump asked about
paying 750 in taxes
trump said well that's a statutory
amount that's like a minimum
fee almost like you pay when you file
and my my accountant said i paid that
didn't make any sense now we have a
different story which is
he actually pre-paid millions of dollars
and i guess that's why they're not on
his return
it's impossible to decipher what he's
talking about none of it is believable
and then this is where it almost seemed
like trump
was was unaware of his surroundings and
not even understanding what he was
saying
he starts using this mafia-esque
language
to accuse biden of giving money to the
big men
nobody could understand what he was
talking about well
i called my accountants underwrote it
i'm going to release them as soon as we
can i want to do it and it'll show how
successful how great this
company is but much more importantly
than that people were saying
750 i asked them
a week ago i said what did i pay they
said sir you prepaid
tens of millions of dollars i prepaid my
tax tens over the last
number of years tens of millions of
dollars i prepaid
because at some point they think it's an
estimate they think i may have to pay
tax
so i already prepaid it nobody told me
that did your account nobody tell you
that
excuse me and it wasn't written whenever
they write this they keep talking about
750
which i think is a filing fee but let me
just tell you i prepaid
millions and millions of dollars in
taxes
number one number two i don't make money
from china you do
i don't make money from ukraine you do i
don't make money from russia
you made three and a half million
dollars joe and your son gave you
they even have a statement that we have
to give 10 percent
to the big man you're the big man i
think i don't know maybe you're not
trump continuing to say by the way
five years later he can't release his
taxes
even the ones from i guess like 2012 at
this point
because he's under audit or ardent as
trump often says and then again
trump saying biden gives money to the
big men
one of the most incoherent attacks of
the night joe biden
just saying this is really simple show
us the returns
to talk about this more broadly respond
very quickly and then i'll get to my
question
why did he's been saying this for four
years
show us just show us stop playing around
you've been saying for four years you're
gonna release your taxes nobody knows mr
president what they do know
is you're not paying your taxes or
you're paying taxes that are so
low when last time he said what he paid
he said
i only pay that little because i'm smart
i know how to game the system
come on come on folks come on man
becoming a very very popular meme from
this debate come on man
now this is a really special moment
because trump tries a hunter biden
conspiracy
and refers to some very strong email and
joe biden perfectly explains that
americans pay tariffs that trump put on
china
trump still doesn't understand how
tariffs work let me know i have to
respond to that
okay very quickly and then we're going
to provide three and a half dollars from
chinatown
after spending ten minutes in office and
being in air force two
number one number two there's a very
strong
email talking about your family wanting
to make
10 million dollars a year for
introductions president trump
on china policy though what's your
number what are you going to do
what specifically are you going to do to
make china pay you've said you're going
to
billions and billions of dollars i just
gave 28 billion
i just gave 28 billion dollars to our
farmers taxpayers china
that's what taxpayers money yeah i know
it's called china china paid 28 billion
and you know what they did to pay it joe
they devalued their currency and they
also paid up
look at how this is four years into the
presidency
and donald trump still thinks that when
you tariff china
chinese people send the united states
treasury money no
our companies when they import things
from china
pay the tariffs the money comes
from american companies and i've said
before
i don't know if trump still doesn't
understand that or is pretending
not to understand it when the topic of
health care came up trump started
talking about
joe wants socialized health care he's
going to destroy
medicare and social security none of
which is true
some of which we wish were true but it's
not biden astutely pointing out
you're running against me i beat those
other people why are you talking about
other people's policies
when he says public action he's talking
about socialized medicine
and when he and and healthcare when he
talks about a public option
he's talking about destroying your
medicare totally destroyed and
destroying your social security
and this whole country will come down
you know bernie sanders tried it
in his state he tried it in a state his
governor was a very liberal governor
they want to make it work
okay
vice president very confused guy he
thinks he's running against somebody
else he's running against
joe biden i beat all those other people
because i disagreed with them
joe biden he's running against joe biden
quickly lining up
retorts to all attacks which was great
to see
wasn't ready in the first debate on that
front
this was maybe the worst moment of the
debate for trump
trump again pulling out this line of
attacking so-called
democrat cities and states which is a
message of complete division
and and this this was pitch perfect
joe biden perfectly responding to that
divisive message
saying listen i'm not going to talk
about blue states in red states i'm a
democrat running for president
i will be the president for everybody
regardless of what state you're in
couldn't have teed it up any better for
joe biden
it was really a big bailout for badly
run democrat
cities and states all right if i get
elected i'm not gonna i'm running as a
proud democrat but i'm gonna be an
american president
i don't see red states in blue states
what i see
is american united states and folks
every single state out there finds
themselves in trouble
they're gonna start laying off whether
they're red or blue
cops firefighters first responders
because
teachers because they have to balance
their budget and you see trump just kind
of nodding and shaking his head like a
fool during that one
even trump seemed to realize that
attacking half the country
when you're depending on a handful of
key battleground states to win
which are very much split blue red
democrat republican not a good idea
the next worst moment for trump was when
he casually
went xenophobic the topic of immigration
came up and trump had no choice i guess
in his mind
in order to really own biden than to
talk about low iq hispanic immigrants
just really
bottom of the barrel stuff here only the
really i hate to say this
but those with the lowest iq they might
come back okay president trump let's
give vice president biden a chance to
respond and then we're going to move on
to this you don't know the law joe
vice president biden your response and
then one hilarious moment was
trump calling himself the best president
of uh four black people since abe
lincoln
and joe biden sarcastically came back
and said you know abe lincoln over here
hasn't done this that and the other
thing
trump doesn't understand it trump
doesn't understand humor trump doesn't
understand
satire it's it's actually sociologically
the most interesting moment
we talk about how trump has no sense of
humor he doesn't seem to get
jokes trump is actually visibly confused
by this joke and
asks what joe biden is talking about
president biden let me ask you
very quickly and then i have a follow-up
question for you abraham lincoln here is
one of the most racist presidents we've
had in modern history
he pours fuel on every single
racist fire every single one he started
off his campaign coming down the
escalator saying he's going to get rid
of those
mexican rapists he's banned muslims
because they're muslims
he has moved around and made everything
worse
across the board he says to about the
poor boys
last time we were on stage here he said
i told him to stand down
and stand ready come on this guy is a
dog whistle about as big as a foghorn
president trump i'm going to give you 10
seconds to respond and then i have a
follow-up he made a reference to abraham
lincoln where did that come in
i mean you said abraham line where did
that no
no you said i said not since abraham
lincoln
has anybody done what i've done for the
black community and i'm gonna say i'm
abraham lincoln i said
not since abraham lincoln has anybody
done
what i've done for the black this is
just so funny
and biden can't help but laugh trump
doesn't understand
satire it's lost on him i don't know
what trump understands less satire
or how tariffs work he seems to not
understand either of them
and then final stunning moments after
the end of the debate
we saw melania trump and jill biden walk
onto the stage
melania approaching donald trump they
seem to barely even say a word to each
other
they look miserable trump not putting a
mask on joe biden immediately puts a
mask on at the end of the debate
emblematic of their respective
perspectives on coronavirus jill biden
embraces joe biden
they look like a normal couple the
trumps look miserable biden
both jill and joe biden try to catch
trump and melania's eye
to say bye to wave by trump doesn't even
acknowledge the biden's presence on
stage
the biden's wave trumps start just
walking off and then you see
it's either melania ripping her hand out
of from trump's hand
or vice versa but just completely
emblematic of
everything that these people represent
so a terrible debate for donald trump
the way i would
summarize it if you if you said how does
it how do you distill what happened
trump spent 90 minutes talking about his
problems
whereas and his victimhood and his being
a martyr
while joe biden talked about the
problems affecting the american people
rather than about joe biden himself
and if you have ever seen a more
lopsided presidential debate
let me know because i can't remember one
we've got uh just a little over a week
left until this election
trump is going to try funny business to
win it
we are at the election 40 45 million
people have already voted that's about a
third of the expected electorate or more
uh let's do it this is it there's
nothing else to wait for
no more debates you can vote now in a
vast majority of states either by mail
or early
let's just do it and let me know your
thoughts about the debate in these last
10 days on twitter where you can find me
at d pacman the david pakman show at
davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important
core insights from each book so it's
perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
welcome back to the show remember the
number one way to support the work we do
grab a membership join pacman.com easy
quick feels good no reason not to do it
uh we are going to hear from some folks
there are people
aching to get on the air with me today
via the david pakman show official
discord
which you can find at davidpakman.com
slash discord that's d-i-c
no i'm sorry d-i-s-c-o-r-d
uh let's start today there are just so
many people it's hard to know where to
start
let's start with mel from florida mel
from florida you're on the air
mel from florida we can hear you yeah
awesome
hi david hi so uh i was playing around
with 5 38's
uh you know where you changed the the
states around on the electoral map
yeah and it looks like even without
knowing if he gets
pennsylvania wisconsin or michigan
biden's chance of
winning jumps to above 99
if he just picks up florida
yes so we were going through some of
these scenarios so what one of the big
things that happened this week is the
supreme court
decided that pennsylvania will continue
counting ballots received all the way up
until three days after
election day and there if we imagine for
a second we won't know pennsylvania on
election night
there are a whole bunch of scenarios
where
if biden is able to take wisconsin and
michigan
and nothing else the election will be
determined by pennsylvania
if biden takes florida but not wisconsin
and michigan
the election will be determined by
pennsylvania but what you're
accurately pointing out is if biden
takes florida
it's unlikely that that's the only
change from 2016
i think if biden takes florida he almost
certainly gets wisconsin and or michigan
that would make pennsylvania unlikely to
be the deciding state and you are very
very much on board which is if biden
gets florida it's it's difficult to
imagine a path for him to lose although
flipping florida alone is not actually
enough for biden to get to 270.
right yeah that's what i was looking at
i just saw that because it's such a big
state
yeah and it is kind of you know in it's
swingable so yeah i was wondering what
your take on that would be
yeah yeah i i mean i agree so we have to
understand the math is florida alone
isn't enough
the reality is if biden wins florida he
probably at least gets either arizona
wisconsin or michigan in which case i
believe it would be enough and
pennsylvania
no longer matters
thank you yeah that was i was all i
really was like wondering about
because of course that's i'm in that
state so
did you already did you vote early by
mail or what did you do
uh no i'm actually gonna vote on
election day
okay um in part because i want to make
sure that there isn't anybody
pounding people at the polls you know
right yeah and if there is
if you can safely film it and get me the
video we we will be covering that
intimate intimidation and the like oh
yeah absolutely
so all right mel thank you so much thank
you
all right mel from florida voting in
person very very
exciting stuff going on there let me go
next to um
hold on a second here let's go to kevin
from new york kevin from new york what's
on your mind today
uh holy crap i'm talking to david paxman
right now
you're on right now my friend i'm a big
fan so basically
a couple like two weeks ago i was
talking to my
my friend talking politics my friend
yeah and he opposes uh the res
there were lockdowns because uh
because because they lose because of the
whole business and jobs
losing to businesses and jobs right and
where does your friend live
uh i i want to stay in anonymous
okay can you tell me what state your
friend lives in
uh i'm not sure he hasn't told me i just
want to stay anonymous
wait a second you have a friend and you
don't know what state they live in
that's very interesting discord friend
he's a discord friend
okay i'm not aware of any state that is
locked down right now so if your friend
lives in a different country then that
would be interesting to know but
either i wasn't sure what he was talking
about either yeah but
he so basically i i i said that we
should give money to the businesses
for that we should give money to
businesses so they can pay their
employees but he's like
and due to unemployment but he's like no
because i'll start the rock
because that's why people are riding
wait he says people are rioting
when businesses get money for employees
he opposes unemployment benefits because
of that
your friend doesn't strike me as that
bright that's what i'm good that's my
only thought
yeah yeah i'm so sorry i mean i'm kind
of nervous because i'm speaking to you
you're doing great oh okay yeah
all right very good yeah i don't know
that i would argue with that friend i
would spend my time doing something more
productive this this friend doesn't
sound like they're making any sense
yeah yeah but what do you think i should
say
i would say listen i don't even know you
or know what state you live in
so it's i i don't even know what you're
talking about and you know i'm going to
go talk to somebody else on discord
that's my genuine advice
oh man okay thank you no problem
all right thank you very much we're
hearing from people from not only all
over the country
but from all over the world but let's go
locally
first or next and go to matt from boston
matt uh what's what's going on with you
hello yeah oh awesome um
yeah so i'm calling i've been trying to
call him for a while
uh so i've had several questions i think
i'm just going to go with one that i
wanted answered to since i originally
started trying to call in which was like
back during the roger stone
uh situation where uh barr
told him to or kind of changed the
prosecutorial i don't remember the
details
of so long ago about uh commuting a
sentence i don't know specifically what
he did
but my question is like several of the
lower level prosecutors resigned
uh because of like cars decision and i'm
wondering like what good does that do
because it seems to me that that he can
just fill those positions
with people that are more sycophants
that will actually go along with those
things all it does is like
do a headlight grab for the day but then
in the end there's
now more significance
in power that can actually get those
things done is that i totally agree with
you this is this is the trump phenomenon
and by the by the way out of curiosity
are you vacuuming or something right now
oh no i'm in a research lab
sounds like very high level air
filtration systems yeah it's a
it's a funky negative 80 degree freezer
that uh
wait you're calling from negative 80
degrees right now
no no there's a freezer next to me that
makes a lot of rain oh my god i was
going to say what are you wearing if
you're
in such a freezer okay so i mean listen
this is the trump thing right this is
the fouchy thing in fact
people say oh should fauci resign in
protest because of what's going on well
then who gets in i mean we already saw
publicly trump replaced fauci with
a neuroradiologist named scott atlas so
this isn't this is a a it's it's a
constant
uh question of weighing resigning in
protest and because you can't take it
and your
your nerves are frayed and your mental
health is destroyed having to work for
these lunatics
on the other side you've got well if i
leave they replace me with someone crazy
so am i not better off by being here and
you're absolutely right
to suggest that they get replaced with
even worse people
yeah because that's like the frustrating
thing because that clip you played with
bolton
yeah where uh if it was hassan he said
like well you didn't resign a protest
versus you know i don't like bolton i i
think it's a fair point
yeah that hassan makes was just like
you're just stuck between a rock and a
hard place and i'm just curious what you
think is the right thing to do
yeah yeah it's very situational there's
no right answer but many times it does
result
to worse people uh be being put in um
thank you so much for the call great to
hear from you all right thank you
all right we're going to take a quick
break but if you are holding don't hang
up because we are going back to the
phones
strongly and powerfully very very soon
quick break
back right after this the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
all right let's hear from some more
folks going next on the david pakman
show discord which is of course
davidpakman.com
discord to let's go to shira from
illinois shira what's going on
shira are you with us shira from
illinois
if you're muted you may have to unmute
yourself
last chance for shira
all right no shira from illinois that's
really too bad
uh let's go next to
um let's go to mario from maryland mario
from maryland what's going on with you
hey what's up d-pack
how you doing good i'm good so it's a
given that amy coney barrett is gonna go
into the supreme court we
she's just gonna go in there's nothing
we can do to stop it i believe so
but uh i've heard from some projections
that she's gonna
go into effect right like about a week
before the election
is there anything that the dems can do
to stall that
so that she goes into effect after the
election because i think it's
it would be really bad if she went into
the supreme court
before the election because she would
have a lot of power to help
trump win those cases in those different
states uh
regarding borders and stuff like that
absolutely and unfortunately i
i really don't know that there is um
i've read i don't even want to describe
it in detail because i'm not even sure
it makes any sense to me but i've read
about
possible procedural things that
democrats might be able to try
but it's like i i basically think you're
right
that it's not uh it's it's maybe not
going to happen
and we're going to have to take the loss
on it i hate to say it but that may be
the
case yeah well thank you for the call
uh my pleasure thank you thank you for
calling in uh there is uh
mario from maryland let's go
next to a gabe from london across the
pond
gabe what's going on over there hello
david
yes please uh please if you can we're
hearing the little discord beeps
um okay is there any way you can mute
those
um sorry so
um anyway it's uh it's great to speak to
you i'm such a big fan
yeah um my question is pretty simple
which is after the election
uh what can be done do you think to stop
the massive amount of misinformation we
see
from places like fox news even
mainstream places like that
because the problem is that it's very
hard uh i'm gonna i'm gonna go
take the and i'm gonna answer it offline
because the discord beeping is uh people
are furious about it i'm not but other
people get furious
the problem really is that in terms of
regulation
there's very little you can do to stop
people from believing
fox news right i mean it's like you
could say let's try to pull fox news off
the air i don't see how you do it
that's just not what this country is is
built on so
you need to essentially just have like
smarter people
who understand who have better
understanding of media literacy
and have the tools they need to protect
themselves from from disinformation
who know how to question a story who
understand how to
research whether they're being told
something that's true or not who can
distinguish between news and opinion
programming so unfortunately
i wish there was something that could be
done to fix
the fox news problem but based on the
the legal infrastructure of this country
i don't see how you do it and it's
really a matter of
having people who can better protect
themselves from the disinformation and
that's pretty pretty damn difficult as
as we've experienced let me go to cass
from edmonton uh cass from edmonton
what's going on
hey david can you hear me you're coming
through loud and clear
perfect awesome i'm from yeah i'm from
edmonton as you know
i've actually been watching the show for
almost 10 years now and wow
that's long yeah i've been doing it
somehow you were watching the show
before i was involved eight years like
since high school that's all i know like
it feels like a decade awesome but um
feels like 40 years to me so all right
but
it actually inspired me to take
political science in school which i'm
doing right now
and and what we're learning about and
something i thought was interesting
in joe biden's town hall is about
kind of the decline of the united states
as a hegemony
and the rise of china and more
specifically
the united states has loss of soft power
and i was really interested in what joe
biden had to say
to the republican when talking about
foreign policy and i thought he kind of
touched on this
um previously this is kind of a
right-wing talking point or do you know
even trump's like
anti-china how do you think that the
democrats
moving forward could address the united
like the united states soft power
issues and kind of strengthening
themselves on the world stage
so there's really specific analysis that
could be done there
that relates to you know as micro as
looking at
where manufacturing and energy
industries are moving globally like that
they would almost be like industry
analyses but i think that we have
fallen so out of favor globally under
donald trump
that there's a much broader analysis
that first has to be done which is
if you look at the three global
superpowers right now
u.s china russia you look at the role of
india as a growing economy you look at
nigeria as an example you know and you
start to go
sort of go down the list um the first
step
to even be back in the picture is we
need just
some basic things to happen a president
who doesn't think
climate change is a hoax created by the
chinese we're no longer even
part of so many of the global
conversations about climate
because of trump's position on climate
that if that doesn't get fixed we're
screwed right number two
um are our uh traditional western
democratic allies
uk germany france canada you know these
places where the relationships have
soured uh because of how donald trump
relates to other people
if that stuff doesn't get dealt with
first which i
really am modern moderately confident
that uh a biden administration would do
on policy we may disagree with them on
some of of of the geopolitics but at
least they would rehab
our image in those relationships that
has to be step one
before we can even have a more serious
conversation about what's going to
happen with china and russia in the next
20 years
yeah 100 i agree i think it's
interesting that joe biden mentioned it
and
hopefully he can address it because i
think a lot of people on the left kind
of shy away from it
i agree bye awesome thank you
cass from edmonton thank you so much for
the uh thank you so much for the call
hope to hear from you
again in the future let's go next to
uh ryan from dc ryan from dc
what's going on hey david uh thank you
for taking my call i've been a long time
listener so
my pleasure thanks for taking the time
um my question is kind of
more of a philosophical one um around
like some general political philosophy
um with texas kind of becoming more
purple potentially even being blue by
say
2030ish um and then the potential of
dc and puerto rico gaining statehood
which
would likely go you know the democratic
route i think
just by some of the general statistics
that we have
currently i'm wondering you know what
would be great about those scenarios is
that
the right would have a very difficult
time winning
the presidency ever again um but i'm
wondering more from a philosophical
standpoint what you think it would look
like
if the democrats were dominating
election after election
in some kind of a one-party system do
you think
that the moderates and the and the more
progressive would kind of
split within the democratic party and
create new parties
what would that america look like that's
very hard to predict and it's like i
could make a prediction but we know that
that
you know it would essentially be
worthless because what do any of us
really know
the one thing i i think though is if
indeed
texas population moves left such that
democrats are really in contention
nationally in texas or even win texas
my guess is that texas republicans would
move to the left and
be back in contention it's sort of like
why do massachusetts
voters who are quite left elect
republican governors so frequently well
they're not electing
you know joni ernst they're electing
people like william weld
uh and charlie baker and others
republicans in massachusetts have moved
left in order to remain viable
so my my instinct is that what you would
see in texas if it really starts to seem
like a like a national republican could
win
is that the texas republican party would
start coming to the left
and they would remain viable and that
would be good because we're we're still
moving to the left if that happens
right yeah i think uh the overton window
would kind of continue to shift left and
and i think that would actually still be
a net positive and
yeah you know they would have to move to
the left just to survive
i i completely i think that's the most
likely scenario you know people think oh
just democrats will win texas from here
until forever well
okay i mean at some point that could
happen but you could also see
republicans
re reinstate their sort of 55-45
majority
by just moving a little bit to the left
right
that's great yeah it was just something
i was kind of uh thinking about and
wanted to kind of bounce it off you so
thanks for taking my call david
my pleasure all right thank you so much
great to hear from you uh let's see who
else we can go to here uh oh you know
what let's go to ronald reagan who is
going to uh uh chime in ronald what's
going on
hey david can you hear me i can
hey uh really good quality on these
discord
calls pristine incredible pristine you
know there's some other shows out there
that haven't figured out the
calling systems but is that right i've
never heard of those i've never seen
those shows
we don't need to go into that but um i
wanted to ask you about the
the limitations of the the sort of obama
uh they go low we go high philosophy
right and how
you know obama came in and did the sort
of gerald ford thing with
you know looking forward not looking
back and treating his uh predecessor as
you know very hands-off um
kid gloves and then i i'm just
i'm wondering if all of this stuff about
trying to like because i think if it
were up to trump you would literally put
obama in jail
yeah and going after their kids you know
trying to get
their kids put in jail and
i i don't see that you know sadly from
my perspective
lighting a fire under under these people
in terms of like
you know changing that sort of dynamic
of
of looking forward and not looking back
i understand there's like some
slippery slope arguments about what
happens in
you know sort of banana republics where
you're just constantly throwing the last
president in jail
on trump charges like i understand that
um fear
but i don't know what do you think about
the sort of limitations of this
philosophy and whether or not you think
that might change
moving forward given the you know what's
happened over the last four years
it it may change but i really just don't
see
any way in which a democratic president
is going to
when we talk about when they go low we
go high i think that you you essentially
need context and so i'll give you
examples where you
have to just apply critical thinking um
trump says
let's jail biden the counter would be if
biden wins
try to get trump jailed i think that
that is that is a losing strategy i
don't that that i don't think is
is what we should do but to give you a
counter example
i believe that the public the uh
campaign finance system we have should
be changed
as long as it's the system we have do i
think
democrats should raise as much money as
they can
and spend it on campaign ads which we
know work and do everything they can to
use that system to get into power
of course of course at a certain point
you're talking about you know
uh um unilateral disarmament
uh should negative ads work do i think
on principle biden shouldn't do negative
ads about trump because i don't really
think that that type of
campaigning should be part of our system
no biden's got to use negative ads and
i'm
perfectly fine with him doing it for for
as long as it's the system we have
what you're talking about about you know
starting to to say oh now that i'm
president i'm gonna direct attorney
general whoever works for biden
to try to look at jailing trump i don't
i just don't see even what the political
benefit is to doing that
raygun yeah sorry you cut out there for
a second no
um yeah no i but i guess
maybe more specifically like do you
think um
do you think they continue like i'm just
thinking about like uh
michelle obama like holding hands with
george w bush
at a i don't remember even whose funeral
that was maybe bush senior but
um do you think that there's even like
an attitude
shift in in treating you know trump as a
legitimate president or do you think
they're gonna just continue
with that that i really hope that we
don't see
and there's a lot of people who
understandably see michelle obama
talking about how she's great friends
with george w bush and then they say
guy's a war criminal who made foreign
policy decisions that led to the deaths
of what hundreds of thousands or even
more in in iraq
she's rehabilitating the image of a of a
war criminal
and i think that that is legitimate and
at the same time
this is a very small group of former
presidents and what
what do you expect to happen for such a
small club
i hope that that does not happen with
donald trump because i see donald trump
as such a different
animal in many ways that than the others
i
i don't want democrats to do that and i
hope that they don't
right thanks david all right by the way
raygun you still there
yeah quick question do you know you're a
lawyer do you know what this greatest
political crime in history that trump is
talking about that was committed by
obama and biden is do you know what law
might have been broken
uh they they spied on his campaign
campaign david i mean you should know
that you're
you report the news okay uh they spied
on his campaign
and uh they abused um fisa
i've heard and um
you know it's just it yeah it's like
watergate but worse
it's worse than water yeah all right
raygun thank you very much
great to hear from you i'm sorry i can't
take any more calls today but i did what
i could we will take a quick break
and take calls again very very soon
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
let's get right into audience questions
for this week first one's interesting
relates to a thing
to a few different things we've talked
about over the last few years and the
question is
what is the most likely future of
socialism
in the united states if you watched the
recent
a state of the union addresses from
donald trump you would know that this
powerful defiant declaration that the
u.s
will never be a socialist country
is both an impossible prediction to make
because the truth is we're terrible at
predicting things even five years out
who knows what the us could look like
20 30 50 100 years out but it's also
particularly
it's meaninglessly propagandistic in the
sense that there's no threat that the us
is about to become socialist despite
donald trump
continuing to campaign on biden's been
taken over by the socialists
the people trump claims are controlling
biden
aren't by and large actual socialists
and certainly there's nothing
socialistic about joe biden's policy so
the fear-mongering about the u.s
becoming socialist
is very very silly but it does seem to
at least activate some of the people on
the right but i think those people are
mostly supporting donald trump anyway
i think it's essentially a wash so then
we get to
a trump-free discussion of the possible
future of socialism in the united states
as i have said before
i have seen no evidence that if the u.s
is to become a socialist country and
again
this is not about my views i'm not a
socialist i'm a social democrat which is
a form of highly regulated
capitalism if the country is to become
socialist
i believe that you would need to see
first of all
actual socialists have some amount of
power in the united states now this
could be socialist groups
or socialist politicians right now i
don't see either
and i believe it would be incremental it
would go through social democracy
accelerationism is the idea when applied
to socialism capitalism
that by accelerating capitalism
which some socialists believe will fail
some marxists some communists believe
will fail you
accelerate the eventual revolution
that will turn the country socialistic
uh
much has been said theoretically about
that and written theoretically about
that i believe that in practice
at this point in time again in five
years maybe i'd have a different view
because things dramatically change
right now i don't see how for example
giving trump another four years and
cutting regulations and giving more
market power
i don't think that if that causes a
breakdown
it results in the united states becoming
socialist
if and so this is why i've said time and
again to actual socialists of which
there are relatively few in the united
states
many of the people who even think they
are socialists aren't really socialists
up for now you should just be joining
the fight for social democracy because
the path too or let me put it a
different way
the best proof that you the united
states should go in that direction
would be to go in that direction and
that would mean
uh looking at health care more like
northern european countries look at it
looking at taxation more the way
northern european countries look at it
look at
education social welfare programs etc
in the last decade we have seen
socialists go from really more of an
insult and not something many people
would use to describe themselves
to kind of like a pretty ho-hum you know
it's just a word
it's almost become like progressive
although it means very different things
where
trump says all his opponents are
socialists very few people really
believe it
young people are more okay with the term
than we've seen people be in a very long
time so i think that
and it's not for me to give advice to
the actual socialists not being one but
if you are an actual socialist you
should capitalize on
the most positive or least negative view
of socialism that there's been in the
u.s in a long time
by pushing the country in any ways that
are possible
in that direction the best argument you
can make
for socialism being great would be for
social democracy to work really well and
if we ever got to that point
then i and the socialists would be on
different sides
but but right now even though many of
the socialists believe they're on a
different side than me
the next step whether you want social
democracy as the end point or you want
socialism as the end point
would be to move in that direction when
it comes to all of the major
uh areas of policy in the united states
it's certainly not going to happen with
another four years of donald trump
hey david if there were a mandatory gun
buyback in the united states
could it really work would people really
participate
very complicated question so let's first
just
make sure we're on the same page if you
mean
could the united states say all guns
must be turned in
and we will buy them off of you you
don't get that
if you don't repeal the second amendment
i i spent some time reading about this
i don't see any way that there could be
a
nationwide overarching umbrella
mandatory gun buyback without changing
the fact
that people do have a right to own
firearms as confirmed by the supreme
court now if you want to look at
something different like for example
a certain type of firearm has been
banned
and if you have one you have to turn it
in you will have a higher success rate
with that
both legally and in terms of getting
getting uh
societal participation but i don't see
how in a country with a second amendment
you can do a mandatory gun buyback so my
first question would be
how do you address the second amendment
you have to dismantle that right
which the supreme court precedent
supports
in order to do it if you could do it
okay
cost really is an issue i mean we have
300 million
firearms in is it 300 or 350 million
firearms
floating around in the united states
this is why when we talk about well
demilitarize the police yes police with
no guns
in the u.s it's tougher because so many
people
have guns in countries where fewer
citizens have guns
sure i think that's an obstacle here uh
so so then what is the cost because of
the number of guns that are floating
around
could be hundreds of billions of dollars
it could be high hundreds of billions of
dollars depending on
how it would be structured i know that
the government can just
you know not even it's not even print
it's digitally create money
but i see that as very tough politically
to
imagine and then if you could get
through the legal and the financial
the truth is that some other much less
aggressive acts
haven't been super successful i looked
at the new york
safe act and it saw of it was
based on assault weapons of uh the
million
that are registered in the state i
believe
only 45 000 assault weapons were turned
in that's very very low compliance now
there are places that have been able to
do this the uk
new zealand australia they have smaller
populations
fewer guns floating around national gun
registries so
by and large the country knows where a
lot of those guns are
and they don't have anything in their
constitution that has deemed gun
ownership a right the
it's it's a these are laws and the laws
can be changed
they had a lot of success there the
problem i have
believing this would be feasible as an
immediate next step in the united states
as some have suggested is that the genie
is out of the bottle in terms of
the second amendment in terms of the
number of guns that are out in
circulation so i think to really
if this is your priority and and i
believe that there is lower hanging
fruit that we should be looking at
first to create a better infrastructure
where then we could maybe start getting
some guns off of the street but if you
want to go first to a gun buyback
you first have to deal with the second
amendment you secondly have to deal with
the financial piece and third
how do you enforce it law enforcement
would not be able to enforce it in even
a few years
given the number of guns that are out
there what exactly
would be the plan i'm not being
defeatist i'm just being a realist and i
would love
for you to tell me where i'm wrong on
this david
if trump loses or even if he doesn't
when he eventually leaves what happens
to the republican party
this is a this is a big topic there's
really a lot here and
i think that the wrong analogy
would be to look at the tea party the
tea party surfaced in 2010
as a sort of libertarian don't tread on
me reactionary
uh counter to barack obama being elected
in 2008
and they got a bunch of people elected
to the house of representatives
their um presidential candidates to the
extent they had them i don't know if
like ted cruz is considered a tea party
guy
um ron paul i think was a tea party guy
but they never had a prominent
presidential candidate that did well
they never had a president and what
happened with the tea party is they were
essentially some of them just lost and
went away
their ideas became kind of
compartmentalized
in the tea party caucus and they've been
more or less integrated into the
republican party
as more libertarian uh
leaning republicans i don't think that
that applies to what we're seeing with
donald trump because
the trump is a movement to the extent
that it is a movement
and a lot of that movement is based just
around trigger the liberals it's a very
stupid movement but
it's arguably a movement nonetheless
they got a president
who got at least four years and maybe
he'll get four more and
60 million votes right that's that's a
lot and maybe maybe more than that in
the upcoming election
so i don't think that in practice
things are going to sort of go back to
normal i do believe
that the more traditional republicans
will pretend that trump never existed to
some degree
they'll start again talking about oh the
deficit you know and all the bs that
they don't really care about
they'll start you know blocking any
effort if it's joe biden any effort that
joe biden makes to get anything done
they um will maybe even start
fomenting protests particularly if they
lose the senate
they'll again kick up the pandering to
the religious right
pandering to the gun rights people
they're going to do all of those normal
things
but it's going to be tougher to really
pretend trump never existed because
trump got a presidency and again the tea
party
never did that and i think what will be
trouble
is that trump is not going to fade into
the twilight the way george w bush did
we covered earlier this week trump says
he might leave the country if he loses
he's been telling all these states north
carolina if you don't vote for me i'll
never come back iowa if you don't vote
for me i'll never come back
um i do think that we may see a quieter
trump if he loses and certainly if he
gets four years and then loses i think
that that will sort of be the end of
trump and he'll be you know quite quite
an
older guy at that at that point uh but
trump-ism
and the fact that trump has at least
three children who seem to have an
interest in remaining in politics
plus a son-in-law plus you know all of
these other kind of hangers on
if trump keeps tweeting to some degree
if if
in the media you continue to see don jr
and eric and ivanka at minimum
then i think the offspring of this
movement will remain for some time so
i think in practice a lot of the future
of trumpism
within the republican party is going to
be affected by things we haven't seen
yet one real question the republican
party is going to have to figure out
if trump loses right now okay we'll be
how do we get a handle of the white
nationalists
the people whose ideology is just to
anger liberals
the so-called cultural warriors focused
on sjws and canceled culture and that
that type of thing how do we get them
under control because
they're completely out of control right
now and if trump loses it will be
evidence that
even with them behind your candidate
it's not enough to win
if trump loses in a moderately large
landslide moderately
large race or in a landslide in a couple
of weeks
the republican party is going to have to
realize these groups aren't even helping
us win
and they're really bad for us we've lost
traditional republicans because of this
group these groups
does the republican party abandon those
groups do they call them out
do they just push them back into
obscurity
still voting republican but not as
comfortable with their ideas in public
as they've been under donald trump
i don't know but all of this put
together suggests to me
that whenever trump leaves you're going
to see the republican party
sort of flail about in a confusion
for some period of time after trump
loses
it may even extend if trump loses in two
weeks
into and beyond the 2022 election where
you would expect
if you have democrats take the white
house in this november
inaugurated in january history suggests
republicans would do well in the 2022
midterms especially if that didn't
happen
there's going to have to be a real
accounting of what what happens you know
what happens to the never trump
republicans the lincoln project
conservatives many of whom are
supporting joe biden
do any of them remain democrats or do
they all go back
all important questions but i think it's
going to be it's going to take more than
three months to figure out even if
donald trump loses in two weeks
which we hope he does we've got a great
bonus show for you today
sign up get instant access at
joinpacman.com
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or listen
to an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for
free and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video